als hätte dieser tag nicht bereits
ausreichend nachrichten produziert die
kanzlerin ist vor die presse gegangen
heute nachmittag hat neue
verhaltensregeln corona regeln für alle
deutschen aufgestellt und verkündet und
direkt nach dieser pressekonferenz der
nächste hammer in dieser corona
nachrichtenzeit es ist die kanzlerin
selbst angela merkel selbst die sich nun
14 tage so die pressemitteilung des
bundeskanzleramt des bundespresseamtes
in häusliche quarantäne begeben muss
paul ronzheimer bild vize bei mir im
studio was wissen wir über die
krankenakte angela merkel so noch gar
nicht fassen in welcher dichte diese
nachrichten im moment hier einschlagen
absolut lieber kein wir wissen momentan
nicht mehr als die offizielle
pressemitteilung das muss man ganz klar
sagen wir haben die pressekonferenz
gesehen und jetzt ich lese sie einfach
mal vor das ist es amtsdeutsch sozusagen
der sprecher der bundesregierung steffen
seibert teilt mit die bundeskanzlerin
wurde nach dem heutigen presseauftritt
davon unterrichtet dass ein arzt der am
freitagnachmittag eine prophylaktische
pockenimpfung bei ihr vorgenommen hatte
mittlerweile positiv getestet wurde